يوم الجمعه عند الساعه السابعه صباحا
بالتوقيت المحلي لغزه يبدا سريان اتفاق
الهدنه المؤقته بين حركه حماس واسرائيل
بيومه الاول من اصل اربعه ايام وفق اعلان
مستشار رئيس الوزراء القطري المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه القطريه في اول ايام الهدنه هذه
ستفرج حماس عن 13 محتجزا لديها وهم من
النساء والاطفال وسيكونون الدفعه الاولى
من 50 محتجزا نص اتفاق الهدنه على افراج
حماس عنه
وسيكون الافراج عن الدفعه الاولى من
المحتجزين لدى حماس عند الساعه الرابعه
عصر اليوم الاول مقابل ذلك وفق اعلان
كتائب القسام ستفرج اسرائيل عن ثلاثه اسرى
فلسطينيين من النساء والاطفال مقابل كل
محتجز واحد تفرج عنه حماس اي 39 اسيرا من
الاسرى في سجونها ستفرج عنهم اسرائيل في
اليوم الاول سيدخل الى كامل قطاع غزه في
يوم الهدنه الاول وعبر معبر رفح 100 شاحنه
من المواد الانسانيه من مواد غذائيه وطبيه
وغيرها اضافه الى دخول اربع شاحنات وقود
وغاز للطهي ومنذ الثانيه الاولى لبدء
الهدنه يفترض ان تتوقف الاعمال القتاليه
من فصائل المقاومه وجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ويتوقف قصف الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه على كامل قطاع غزه في حين ان
الطائرات المسيره الاسرائيليه ستتوقف عن
التحليق فوق محافظات وسط وجنوب غزه طوال
ايام الهدنه اما في محافظتي غزه وشمال غزه
فلن تتوقف الطائرات الاسرائيليه المسيره
سوى ست ساعات من العاشره صباحا حتى
الرابعه عصرا اما حركه سكان القطاع فينبغي
ان تكون وفق الاتفاق متاحه وامنه خلال
ايام الهدنه الاربعه من شمالي قطاع غزه
الى جنوبه عبر شارع صلاح
الدين